[Musique]
toujours d'après quand nous aurons des
nuits
ce ne sera pas un retour aux jours
d'avancé oui il y a eu des ratés il ya
eu de l'impréparation aussi mais pour
jean garrigues ce qu'a également révélé
cette crise c'est la solidité des
institutions de la vème république
ce qu'a révélé cette crise et qu à côté
du discours présidentiel est un discours
de mobilisation de rassemblement de
dramatisation aussi de deux des
événements et un autre discours qui
était possible était le discours du
premier ministre
un discours plus pragmatique plus proche
et souci des préoccupations des citoyens
et finalement que ce ce discours primo
ministériel a conquis toute sa place et
l'a vu d'ailleurs dans les sondages que
edouard philippe finalement était celui
qui avait émergé dans cette crise un peu
à la manière dont on mai 68 premier
ministre de l'époque georges pompidou
s'étaient révélés comme celui qui avait
le mieux et qui avait dire presque
entièrement géré gérer la crise donc
c'est assez intéressant voir cette
résurgence du couple exécutif et
notamment du rôle du premier ministre
cette crise elle nous indique une
direction vers la recréation de l'état
providence la solidarité la
reconstruction d'une souveraineté
industrielle et plus d'égalité
la revalorisation des métiers de la
santé ou de l'éducation par exemple
assortie d'une réorganisation de ses ses
systèmes
j'irai vers une véritable et
concentration des pouvoirs pour donner
plus de pouvoirs et de moyens et de
responsabilité et de légitimité au
pouvoir territoriaux et puis j'irai
aussi peut-être vers une initiative vers
une sorte de plan marshall européen
grand plan d'investissements en matière
de transport de logement sociaux et de
transition écologique c'est fondamental
donc voilà les trois mesures que c'est
très globale que que je que je
conseillerai c'est à dire des mesures
fortes
des mesures qui représenterait une
véritable rupture avec ce qui existe
aujourd'hui
la déconcentration des pouvoirs il
s'agit de l'un des piliers de la
décentralisation et consiste à
transférer des compétences de l'état
vers les collectivités territoriales
c'est l'un des thèmes qui revient très
fort ces dernières semaines ce qui le
revendique demande à ce que l'on tire
tous les enseignements de la gestion
allemand de la crise
[Musique]